The one piece manga finally showed us the
strongest crew in one piece history as the
Rocks crew takes the stage for the very first
time in the story on God Valley at the same
time as a young Roger with Luffy’s straw
hat!
And just wow, after so many years of talking
about this legendary pirate crew, we are finally
seeing them all together here at God Valley.
And even though Oda is still teasing us by
not showing Rocks D. Xebec’s full appearance,
it is still amazing to see all of the insane
members of this crew, including some we didn’t
expect.
But before we get into all the new reveals,
it seems like the Rocks’ true objective
was to obtain these crazy devil fruits that
the Celestial Dragons are offering as prizes
for the tournament.
We can tell because we see Big Mom almost
immediately go after the devil fruits, and
capture what will later be Kaido’s fruit,
but it is also super interesting to think
about what other fruits could be in these
treasure chests.
Of course, we know Kuma’s fruit was another
of the six, but what about the other four?
There are a few real possibilities here based
on other characters that are here at God Valley.
For example, we never knew for sure when Whitebeard
ate his Tremor fruit, so I could very easily
imagine that Whitebeard got his devil fruit
from one of these prize chests.
Another logical possibility is the Float Float
fruit.
Because in case you forgot, the Golden Lion
Shiki is here and at some time he ate this
devil fruit which allows him to make anything
float in the air, including himself.
Another random but super exciting option is
some sort of wind or weather devil fruit because
while Luffy’s father, Monkey D. Dragon,
has not shown up yet, I do wonder if his wind
related powers could be related to one of
the devil fruits in the chests.
On top of all that, one fruit that I saw people
speculating about is the Nika fruit, but honestly
I don’t think the Nika fruit is that strong
of a possibility since the Gorosei always
wanted to get their hands on it, but never
seemed to be able to.
I even think it is possible the Rocks already
ate the Nika fruit, since he was able to bring
together such a stupidly powerful crew similar
to Luffy.
But even if that’s not the case, another
likely option for one of the treasure chests
is the Darkness fruit, which just makes perfect
sense to be one of the prizes here.
I mean it is the ultimate Logia devil fruit,
and I’ve even made a theory in the past
that Rocks was after the Darkness fruit.
Plus if you want even more evidence, we already
know that Blackbeard was greatly influenced
by Rocks, with his ship name and his goal
to rule the world, so wouldn’t it make sense
that Rocks wanted the darkness fruit, but
was somehow stopped from eating it, which
left Blackbeard to fulfill that desire later
on?
It makes sense to me at least.
But if the devil fruits weren’t Rocks’
true goal, then what was?
Well, by looking at his main goal of taking
over the world, a pretty easy answer would
be that he just wanted to come and wipe out
all the world nobles.
Which, honestly, yes, please do.
The world would be much better off without
them, but if that was his real goal, then
we have to ask once again, why would Roger
stop him?
In fact, they have a short, but pretty interesting
exchange in this chapter where Roger tells
Rocks to stop, but then Rocks tells Roger
to stay out of his way.
Which isn’t a lot, but it clearly shows
that Roger knew what Rocks was doing and didn’t
like it.
And since we know Roger was a good guy, it
is kinda hard to believe that Rocks was doing
anything positive like wanting to free the
slaves.
And while that’s basically all we got from
those two legends, the reveal of Rocks’
crew gave us some SHOCKING new information.
Because out of all the people in the world,
who would have expected that ELDER NYON, who
was the Empress of Amazon Lily a few generations
ago, was actually a part of this world-conquering
crew?
Like seriously, what is she doing here???
She never gave off any powerful vibes when
she let Boa Hancock literally throw her out
of a window, so did she have some other role
or purpose on the crew?
It’s pretty easy to imagine that she was
actually in love with someone since that is
a common theme for the Empresses, but was
it Rocks or someone else on the crew?
And while we’re talking about former Empresses,
this actually makes me wonder if all the former
Empresses fell in love with powerful pirates.
For example, Elder Nyon possibly loved someone
on Rocks’ crew.
Shakky here fell in love with Rogers’ right
hand man, Rayleigh.
Boa of course is head over heels for Luffy,
and there is actually one more Empress before
Boa that we aren’t currently aware of.
But now I’m actually wondering if it could
be someone like Makino was this missing Empress
who seems to be in a relationship with Shanks.
Which I know sounds crazy, but who else fits
with the timeline and is in love with a super
strong pirate?
Anyway, we also got to see the young appearance
of Miss Buckingham, who not surprisingly looks
exactly like her clone, Stussy.
Which is always funny to me how some characters
somehow shrink and get super wrinkly with
age.
But she definitely has something going on
with Whitebeard as we even see her sitting
on his shoulders.
So maybe they really did get it on and this
guy really is Whitebeard’s son.
Then we have one more member who is either
Silver Ax or Wang Zhi, and they look somewhat
like Kaido does.
There’s also John, who we see chugging down
some booze just like we saw his zombie in
Thriller Bark.
Of course, we also have Shiki, who looks as
he did before chopping off his legs in Impel
Down.
And man, I’m still really wishing we got
to see Rocks because I’m actually kinda
worried we aren’t going to come back to
God Valley for quite some time.
But before we get more into the future, we
of course have to discuss this young chad,
Roger, in all his full Straw Hat glory.
Man, I’m getting goosebumps just seeing
him like this.
And joining the fight with him we have his
right hand, Rayleigh, as well as his other
top commander, Scopper Gaban, along with his
other crew members.
And wow, I’m just so excited to finally
see them in their prime.
Clearly, they are going to oppose Rocks and
his crew, but what else is going to happen
here?
I
think it is pretty likely the Holy Knights
join in the battle as well, and we even met
a few more of them in this chapter.
Like this one who looks like some kind of
royalty, this young woman, this gas mask wearing
dude, plus a younger looking girl with a hat
covering her eyes.
Which means we have to ask just how strong
are these fighters?
I want them to be able to put up a fight here,
and I definitely think Garling is a top-tier,
but can they really match up with some of
the strongest fighters to ever live?
I’m not sure, but the battle isn’t complete
without one more hero, and that is of course
Monkey D. Garp, who apparently was off on
vacation before being told that stuff was
about to go down on God Valley.
Which honestly, this makes me feel a lot better
about Garp’s role in all this because he
clearly wasn’t already protecting the Celestial
Dragons at their tournament.
I mean, if he was there and letting that happen
it just wouldn't feel right.
But that’s not the case because it seems
like he is just showing up at the same time
as Roger and Rocks and will participate in
the battle.
In fact, it seems more likely that this event
is what caused Garp's disgust for the Celestial
Dragons in the first place.
Now, what will happen after the battle?
Clearly, we know Rocks was “defeated”,
but I have to wonder if that is truly the
case.
There are theories out there that Rocks is
still alive or somehow living inside of Blackbeard,
so I know I’ve said this like three times
already, but I really can’t wait to see
what happens with this battle, the devil fruits,
and even the slaves.
But speaking of slaves, I don't think anyone
was expecting to see what happened in this
chapter with Kuma and the rest of the young
revolutionaries.
At least not this soon.
Because in this chapter we learned that the
three young kids’ escape plan was to steal
the devil fruits that the Celestial Dragons
are offering as the reward for their twisted
hunting competition.
And despite all the crazy powerful fighters
on this island, the kids basically succeeded.
I mean Ivankov got stopped by a young Big
Mom before he could run away with Kaido’s
dragon fruit.
Of course, Ivankov isn’t winning that fight
and she stole the fruit from him, which confirms
what we were told in Wano that Big Mom got
this particular fruit at God Valley.
However, that setback didn’t stop Kuma from
stealing and eating the Paw Fruit, which luckily
for them is the perfect ability to allow the
three kids to escape.
However, before they can leave they are confronted
by Saint Saturn here who once again shows
off his incredible flames and what we think
is haki lighting even in his human form.
Seriously, I’m thinking more and more that
these Gorosei are just supremely powerful,
even though they are total scum bags.
And Kuma even says as much when he yells at
Saturn that it isn’t fair that the World
Nobles are born with such power and authority.
But what’s even crazier is that Kuma says
that he would free people if he had the power
to do so AND THEN Saturn says that is exactly
why people like him and his race must be erased.
Like, seriously???
I don’t know if these Gorosei have just
lived so long they just think of people like
trash, but it is incredible that this is the
Gorosei’s true perspective.
So much for the idea that the Gorosei were
actually good people.
But after this, Kuma uses his new powers to
push himself, Ivankov, and Ginny all the way
to his former home, the Sorbet Kingdom.
Which is a bit unbelievable if you ask me
that he was able to be that accurate pushing
across the world literally right after eating
the fruit, but okay I’ll go along with it
because this is a twist I wasn’t expecting,
at all.
I think most people were thinking the slaves
would spend at least a few chapters here,
but this change is both super interesting
and somewhat disappointing.
And starting with the downside, it appears
that this is the end of Kuma’s involvement
on God Valley.
Which more than likely means we are going
to have to wait even longer to see the real
battles here.
It makes sense though that we would continue
with Kuma since this is his flashback, but
still, I wouldn’t be surprised if we have
to wait until a full Roger flashback or something
like that later on to really see what happens
in this legendary battle.
It’s not all disappointment though because
with Kuma now out of the battle, we do have
to ask what happened to him, Ivankov, and
most importantly, Ginny.
Because the three main things we know about
Kuma’s story is that he will at some point
need to become the ruler of Sorbet Kingdom,
meet up with Luffy’s father to become a
revolutionary, and become a Warlord slash
government puppet.
Plus somewhere in there Bonney is born, or
maybe cloned?
We’ll talk more about that in just a minute,
but I honestly don’t know in what order
all of this will happen.
In this chapter, it seems like Kuma and Ginny
are going to end up being in some sort of
relationship and living peacefully in the
Sorbet kingdom, but that obviously can’t
last forever.
Let’s talk about Ginny though because I
am super curious to learn what actually happened
to her.
But first we learned that Ginny is the reason
that Roger and Rocks came to God Valley in
the first place.
Because not only is she good at sneaking around,
but she is also a genius when it comes to
Den Den Mushis.
So with those skills she was able to transmit
the Celestial Dragon’s location out to the
world.
Which makes me wonder if she was working for
the pirates all along or if this was just
some random transmission.
But what’s even more interesting from this
chapter is that because it seems she is settling
down with Kuma, she is most likely Bonney’s
mother.
And honestly she has been alive WAY LONGER
than I originally thought.
I definitely thought she would die at God
Valley, but we have to ask the unfortunate
question of how is she going to die?
Because there is no sign that she is alive
in the current story.
She will have to be alive for a while longer
at least until she can have their baby.
Another possibility though is that at some
point Kuma and Ginny meet a much younger Vegapunk
and instead of Ginny being a mother Vegapunk
actually makes a clone using her DNA, so really
who knows at this point.
And with all of this going on I still get
the feeling that there is more to Rocks’
story than just getting defeated during this
battle.
I mean, this was literally the moment that
reshaped the entire pirate world and surely
Rocks is just going to tap out after one fight,
right?
Plus, he and Roger were both part of the legendary
D clan and there are so many crazy theories
about him living on, that I wouldn’t be
surprised if Roger somehow let him live.
But if you want to know EVERYTHING that we
know about Rocks D. Xebec, you can watch this
video right here.
Shanks for watching, and I’ll see you in
the next one.